I think we have domestically we have to
address for problems and we have to
address them relatively soon we have to
address the global warming energy
problem as I said I do think we have the
technologies I do think we need to put
in the infrastructure and incentives
just to let our best inventors and our
manufacturing go while second we need to
reform the tax system to make it more
fair and to bring down income inequality
and I do think that's going to be very
important for funding initiatives third
we need to change our health care system
to get a sustainable healthcare system
that does guarantee everyone high
quality care and keeps the cost
constraint and the last is we need to
invest in education I think those are
our four big domestic issues and I think
they're all within our grasp and I think
we need to do it for posterity
as far as the world goes I think the
global warming environment energy
complex of problems needs to be
addressed and I think we can address
that I think we do need to figure out
how to bring development to other parts
of the world it's clear that China and
India are developing they are addressing
their poverty problem they still have
many poor people but they have engines
of development the engines of innovation
that are going to solve their problem
when I travel to Africa in two parts of
Latin America that is simply not on the
mark they they have political and
domestic and cultural problems which
they themselves need to address but they
also need help in addressing long-term
sustainable development issues we've
been very bad about that the all the
investments of the World Bank have been
not great all the American foreign aid
tends to be more for our farmers than
for them we need to integrate them into
the world economy and I think we need to
pick out some countries and to really
show that it can work and work hand in
hand with them about political reform
and corruption reform clearly Africa has
huge problems I actually having traveled
there many many times think that
colonial colonialism clearly has a part
but the fact is the big man syndrome
isn't a result of colonialism the
corruption the the suppression of women
is not those are not problems of
colonialism those are endemic cultural
problems of the of the people and they
need to begin to overcome them and there
are some places which are very helpful
Molly which is an incredibly poor
country the average per capita income
there is under two hundred dollars a
year is has had a stable transfer of
power and government and you know that's
a very hopeful sign now we have to give
them a stable economy and figure out how
they can actually develop and work with
them on that and I think that there are
other places which could be big
successes but it's going to take
patience it takes investment it takes a
long-term strategy that's not something
the United States is very good i mean
the long term we are awful at the
long-term
I don't want to prescribe to everyone
although I easily pick and tell you what
I think but I do think we all need to be
a very conscious about our energy
consumption our family has gone carbon
neutral it's trivially easy to go on the
web and become carbon neutral we bought
a prius we're going to buy our second
Prius as cars so I think people
especially the upper middle class who
can afford it needs to be much more
conscious of its energy consumption I do
think that collectively we need to
figure out what our contribution is the
people i mean the this issue of taking
without giving is something that I find
very very bothersome I I mean we you
know we live an incredibly good charmed
life we need to stop being so
self-indulgent about it and I would say
five years ago I was doing some work in
Uganda and I took my kids to you again
the family went to Uganda for three
weeks nothing cures your kids of
consumption and the conspicuous
consumption of having the latest this
the latest fashion of that is going to
African seeing other people how other
people live and then being a shopper at
secondhand clothing stores is like
grilled into you wanting to do good for
people around the world is something
that's very very powerfully motivating
for you I certainly think that's
something that I see a lot of kids in
this generation of college students
being very interested globally and
wanting to get involved that way I think
it's got to be much much more in
positively influenced and much more
widely available to kids